- Nice to meet you.
- Oh my God, nice to meet you.
- Oh my God.
- I love this.
- Thank you.
- You are so adorable right now.
Your whole outfit and you
have a gold medal around you.
That's it. That's it. That's amazing.
Can I just feel how heavy it is?
- Yeah.
- Okay, fine. Fine.
I just wanna feel how-
- You can wear it.
It's yours.
- Oh my god
I just wanna put it on.
I'm just gonna like, well,
I'd like to thank my mom for
always being there for me
and for the best coach
in the world, Michael.
(Kelly laughs)
No, this is amazing.
- Thank you.
- You now you've got two,
you're just collecting them.
- I know.
- Have y'all met before?
- No.
- Nice to meet you. May I?
- Yeah of c- Oh.
- It's amazing.
(audience laughs)
- Everybody's laughing.
- It's like a weird poem, like-
- It's like a thing.
Everyone's like "I've touched one".
- It's really heavy.
- [Kelly] It's so heavy!
- [Chloe] It is heavy.
It's, also like longer than my other one.
So every time I walk, it like
smacks me in the stomach.
- [Kelly] Oh. But your cross to bear.
It's an amazing one to bear.
It's like Awesome.